je m'appelle laura j'ai 25 ans et je
viens de bois d'arcy et j'ai été élue
miss supranational ile-de-france 2022
depuis janvier dernier le rapporte
fièrement son écharpe dans les rues de
bois d'arcy la jeune arcisienne d'un
mètre 73 a été sélectionné pour
participer à ce rendez-vous qui figurent
dans le top 5 des concours de beauté les
plus renommés au niveau mondial un
challenge avant de devenir diplômés
notaire l'année prochaine c'est avant
tout pour concrétiser un rêve de petite
fille et je pense que comme j'étais à ma
septième année de droit c'est le moment
ou jamais de se lancer
j'ai pas fais du journalisme j'ai pas
fait de la mode donc le concours des
miss ça me permet d'avoir une petite
porte d'entrée dans ce monde et entre
voir à quoi ça ressemble actuellement
lowrie dans la dernière ligne droite
c'est ti vinoy ce passionné de voyages
et de surf participera à l'élection
nationale programmée le 5 juin prochain
roubaix elle sera face à une vingtaine
de candidates pour mettre toutes les
chances de son côté la miss regarde
régulièrement les dernières éditions du
concours on a vraiment à le côté un peu
garni avec toutes les belles robes et
serra qui font qu'ils font rêver les la
petite fille la petite fille qu'on en
nous
outre sa je pense vraiment que c'est une
aventure c'est une aventure humaine qui
doit être incroyable je pense qu'aucune
fille regrette d'avoir participé à ce
type de concours pour remporter ce
concours lors a également décidé de
confectionner son propre costume
régional avec l'aide d'une amie car s'il
y en a encore un mois pour terminer sa
robe sur le thème de versailles de marie
antoinette
c'est le premier prototype il manque
après tout le tout le tissu qu'on va
mettre par dessus là c'est vraiment on
va dire le patron du costume et on va
devoir travailler pour avoir le costume
final un costume pour éblouir le jury et
sa famille c'est d'ailleurs avec ses
proches que laura partage son rêve et
notamment avec julia sa nièce de quatre
ans et demi
tu as vu la photo de candidature j'étais
commence sur la photo de candidature
c'est le meilleur soutien c'est le fan
club l es fans avaient elles mêmes robes
des robes que laura espère porter
jusqu'à l'élection miss supranational à
l'international si elle remporte le
concours français en juin elle
s'envolera pour la pologne à la mi
juillet 12e édition qui réunira 76 pays
sur scène devant plus de 650 millions de
téléspectateurs un véritable rêve pour
l'illinois